et maintenant gros plan sur l'art des
rues les jeunes des banlieues sont
invités ce week-end à partager leurs
expériences artistiques à la grande
halle de la villette
au programme musique danse et cinéma
mais les jeunes sont moins nombreux que
prévu peut-être à cause du ticket
d'entrée plutôt cher valérie war et
olivier tu y es tu leur groupe s'appelle
ideal j ils viennent des quatre coins de
la banlieue ils sont tout à la fois
musicien rappeur tagueurs ils sont venus
à la villette pour faire connaître leur
culture celle de la rue avec des actions
comme celle ci je pense qu'on peut faire
quelque chose pour les jeunes qui ont un
coin certain talent comme celui là le
but de cette manifestation c'était un
petit peu de de passer au delà de la
stratégie de l'échec qui existe dans nos
banlieues est plutôt de montrer ce qui
s'y passe de montrer les gens qui ont
une expression et qui ont un désir de
vivre autre chose
deux mille jeunes des quartiers
défavorisés ont investi la grande halle
pour le week end
la culture des banlieues à paris oui
mais pour quel public les organisateurs
espèrent attirer les parisiens branchés
mais aussi les jeunes des cités
tous devront d'abord mettre la main à la
poche son bien nous avons payé 110
francs comme s'en prend pour une journée
pour les jeunes des banlieues oui en
plus la plupart sont des étudiants et
je trouve ça un peu excessif voire les
bénéfices iront à l'association la
maison des enfants du monde ils
serviront à financer un complexe
socio-éducatif au brésil pour les gamins
des rues alors sans four l'entrée c'est
cher mais pour l'organisateur c'est le
prix de la solidarité
quitte à exploiter la mode banlieue oui
j'utilise mais si j'utilise pour dire
quelque chose ça va moi je m'en fous ou
quoi
il préfère utiliser ça dans cette
direction là avec une répartition juste
des richesses
plutôt que de faire du show biz et de me
balader en rolls autant que la
solidarité en compte ce soir sur
quelques têtes d'affiché khaled et
bertignac seront en concert pour inciter
les jeunes des banlieues à passer à la
caisse